time now for morning rounds I look at
the medical news of the week first up an
issue affecting global health a
large-scale study released this week in
the New England Journal of Medicine
examined the impact of obesity across
the planet our chief medical
correspondent dr. Jon LaPook took a
closer look
when 31 year old Carlos Lazos left the
Army Reserve it didn't take long for him
to gain 70 pounds start eating more
fried food a lot of fried foods his
lifestyle as a long-distance truck
driver was putting him on the road to
diabetes
he's now dieting and exercising but his
experience is shared by millions across
the globe this week's report found that
worldwide in 2015 an estimated 604
million adults at 108 million children
were obese in the u.s. almost 13% of
children the highest rate in the world
the highest and adults was in Egypt at
about 35 percent professor azim Majeed
from Imperial College London is one of
the study authors he says diets high in
calories are a major reason but there's
another culprit in many of these
countries there's been quite a rapid
change example in employments away from
high physical activity jobs like farming
or laboring towards more lower access to
jobs like working in offices excess
weight accounted for 4 million deaths
worldwide 70% from cardiovascular
disease and it turns out almost 40
percent of those deaths were in people
who were overweight not obese I think
people probably now know that being a
piece is is Patra health but I think
less people know dipping of what is also
passed
as well someone five foot nine weighing
169 to 202 pounds is considered
overweight 203 pounds or more obese dr.
Bruce Lee is a global obesity expert at
Johns Hopkins University the health
effects include different types of
chronic diseases like type 2 diabetes
heart disease stroke many different
cancers are associated with increased
weight or being overweight or obese so
John what do we do about this
well there are measures that you can do
as an individual and then what can you
do as society this is a huge problem and
I think you really do need societal
steps systemic changes I mean individual
we all try it so one of the toughest
things in the world to do right I'm not
saying there's not a role for that but
it's really tough and it's clearly not
successful as a society there have been
efforts in small areas like Albert Lea
Minnesota where everybody gets together
and says let's change the community
let's put in more walking paths let's go
to the cafeterias and get rid of the
junk food and put in better food let's
go to the chefs and the people who own
the restaurants had put in better things
on the menus and they've had success so
you try to create an atmosphere an
environment will you trip over healthy
behavior yes you don't have to make all
these choices all the time and then
there's also I interviewed Michelle
Obama a while back about you know the
whole business about selling junk food
to kids and it's really tough what she
said to me made a lot of sense which is
they want to sell you their stuff red so
if we don't buy their stuff that's junk
then maybe they'll start selling us
stuff that's healthy yeah our next topic
is some one related to our previous
discussion cardiovascular health
specifically it's treatment with
prescription drugs a new review
published by the European Heart Journal
looked at the gender differences when it
comes to the use and prescription of
cardiovascular drugs so dr. Liu what did
we learn about the gender differences
when it comes to these kind of drugs
well first of all to put it in context
the reason why this is important is a
lot of the research on drugs about how
it gets absorbed about what kind of
effect it has has been on predominantly
males including even on male animals
rats in the in the laboratory and so we
don't know enough and we know this for
years now we don't know enough about
women we also don't know enough about
minorities
it's basically been done in a
homogeneous population so you take a
look at a pill we know that women are
obviously different from men on the
outside but they're different on the
inside yes we are
yes you are and then that's good vive la
différence but you got to understand the
difference and you take a pill you you
swallow it
well gastric acid is actually lower in
women than in men and there are other
factors that make it so that the
absorption is different then you think
about how does it get distributed
throughout the body well women have a
higher percentage of body fat they tend
to be smaller they tend to have less
blood volume less blood plasma and so
the way that it gets distributed
throughout the body is different then
you get to the target area the cell
itself where the medicines taking effect
there are differences by there even on a
cellular level they're generated by
hormones and by the way throughout the
menstrual cycle the hormones change and
in pregnancy something you may be aware
after menopause so there are all these
different areas and then finally how
quickly does the body get rid of the
medication how does it metabolism in the
liver excreted in the kidneys that has a
difference by sex awesome Wow okay so
the review also looked at the difference
in treatment in treatment what did it
find there and we tend to we've known
this too that we tend to under treat
women when it comes to cardiovascular
disease so we do less prevention less
preventive medicines when they need
medicines for treatment we tend to under
do that when they need procedures we
under do that and we also they know
there's been a big education push to
teach people that women can have
atypical symptoms when it comes to heart
disease right they don't have to have
the crushing chest pain they can have a
little bit of nausea a little bit of
fatigue and things like that so doc
short of getting more female lab rats
what do we need to do to improve our
understanding of the gender differences
well we do need to have more female drug
rats and we also need to have more women
in these trials so the NIH I have to say
you have to give them credit they've
made a big push for this and it's
actually mandated by law that they
include more more women in these studies
have more diversity and they're trying
to do that so you include them in the
trials and in addition you have to think
about how you report it out because when
you report it out you can't just say
here's the result - break it down by
gender right and hopefully in
in subgroups to say this is what happens
with women this is with minorities etc
etc so we still have a long way to go